investigators in Moscow Idaho are
looking for people in a specific vehicle
that could hold clues in the murders of
four University of Idaho students it's
actually the first specific request for
information about a person who may have
been in the area when the murders were
committed long crimes and Jeanette Levy
has the latest on The Plea for help from
Moscow Idaho
investigators at the Moscow Police
Department aren't
much about why
for information about this vehicle other
than they say the person or people who
were inside that night may have
information critical to this homicide
investigation
this is a Hyundai Elantra between the
years of 2011 to 2013 that's similar to
the vehicle police say was in the
immediate area of the King Road home
when Kaylee gonsalves Maddie Mogan Ethan
Chapin and Zana kernodle were
senselessly murdered in their sleep I
knew Ethan really briefly in a class
that we had I think it was last fall
seemed like a really good dude so pretty
sad to hear the news and it's also the
one person that I knew in Sigma Kai Max
Keim lives across the street from the
home and said he didn't know the young
women who lived there but he said it's
loud most nights especially with college
students partying on weekends the
request for information about the
Hyundai Elantra came the same day
moscow's police chief and other officers
removed Maddie Kaylee and zanna's
personal items from the home so their
families can retrieve them boxes full of
clothes shoes and other items loaded
into the back of a truck to be returned
to the families almost one month into
the investigation police say they still
have no suspects we still continue to
work on the premise that we believe this
was a targeted incident we're unsure
we're still making the determination
whether that was the actual residence or
the individual or individuals inside an
event is planned for Thursday evening in
Moscow to remember the four young
students k Haley Gonzalez Maddie Mogan
Ethan Chapin and Zannah kernodle people
will be able to write notes of
remembrance and post them in town in
Moscow Idaho I'm Anjanette Levy for Law
and crime daily
and and Jeanette and I actually took a
deeper dive into what Idaho State Police
communications director Aaron snow who
you just saw had to say we did this on
loan crimes podcast sidebar
who do you believe was targeted and he
said they still don't know now he that's
what he's saying he said they don't know
if it was one person targeted in the
house more than one or if it was the
house itself and I said in response like
what do you mean burglary gone wrong and
he's like you know and he said but
they're getting these test results in
from the crime lab they're going through
video and all of these different things
I'm sure they're going through the
victims cell phones and social media
accounts and there are people all over
this town who've been interviewed by
Moscow police and the FBI and Idaho
State Police so I thought it was
interesting that he they still don't
know or still won't say whether they
think it was the people targeted or the
house and there were other things I
asked him about too you know when are we
going to get to see this now we'll hear
this 9-1-1 call I mean usually you hear
a 911 call pretty early on and he would
he said you know he didn't think it
would be released immediately but he
thought it might come sooner rather than
later
and you can hear more from Anjanette on
our podcast sidebar I actually spoke
with her about what she's learned on the
ground in Idaho and we're going to
continue of course to follow all updates
on this story not only on the sidebar
podcast but also here on Long crime
daily we're following a major
development in two big cases that have
impacts in the United States and Beyond
two women looking to be released from
jail one Windsor Freedom while the other
has to go back to her cell Brittany
Greiner the U.S Olympian and WNBA star
was officially officially released from
a Russian jail as part of a prisoner
swap and Courtney klenny the only fans
model accused of throwing a knife at her
boyfriend and killing him was denied
Bond so let's dive into a little bit
more on Brittany greiner's release first
so the Basketball Star was in Russian
custody for nine months after she says
she accidentally put Vape canisters with
cannabis oil in her luggage she was
traveling back to Russia where she plays
basketball in the off season and she
said she had no Criminal Intent the U.S
state Department declared that she was
unlawfully detained in may but she was
sentenced to nine years in prison
officials agreed to release Greiner in
exchange for the U.S releasing Victor
boot a convicted Russian arms dealer
known as The Merchant of death the
exchange of prisoners happened in Abu
Dhabi but left behind was Paul Whalen a
marine convicted by Russian officials of
spying in 2020 he was sentenced to 16
years behind bars greiner's wife Cheryl
who calls Brittany BG spoke alongside
President Joe Biden at the White House
on Thursday she said she'll continue to
fight for other prisoners like Paul
Wellen to be freed
today my family is whole but as you all
are aware there's so many other families
who are not whole and so BG's not here
to say this but I will gladly speak on
her behalf and say that BG and I will
remain committed to the work of getting
every American Home including Paul whose
family is in our hearts today as we
celebrate BG being home we do understand
that there are still people out here who
are enduring what I endured the last
nine months of missing tremendously
their loved ones so thank you everybody
for your support
um and today it's just a happy day for
me and my family so I'm going to smile
right now
um thank you
now negotiations and bargaining had been
going on for months as Griner sat in
prison but does the trade make sense a
basketball player in exchange for a
weapons dealer international law
attorney David to furry weighs in
it was gonna hurt for both sides say you
know Putin didn't want to give up
Brittany Greiner because he knew he had
something of value and he wanted to keep
that in his back pocket and the U.S you
know we're trying to follow the rule of
law and Victor boot had been convicted
of very serious crimes and and sentenced
fairly to 25 years and so it's tough for
us to release someone like that and it
said you know we worry about the message
that sends to the world to to you know
to Global criminals that they can get
out of jail in the U.S uh if their home
country uh uses an American as Leverage
all right let's talk about it joining me
right now is long crime daily co-host
and public defender Brian buckmeyer
Brian this is actually a lot more
controversial than people think you know
while some wanted to release from those
Dreadful conditions there were others
who believed she broke the law and that
she deserved the punishment where do you
stand on it yeah Jesse the controversy
doesn't end just there should she be
punished for her crimes because don't
forget in many states of this country
what she did is illegal now the
headlines Thursday morning were filled
with brittner grinding Greiner sorry is
coming home almost immediately BG is
coming home began to trend on Twitter
now Greiner was arrested for having
cannabis oil cartridge cartridges on her
in Moscow at an airport back in February
but in July the by the administration
recommended a prisoner exchange for
Victor boot The Merchant of death as he
is also known as an arms dealer Who Sold
weapons to Rogue governments and
Warlords boot was supposed to do 25
years in federal prison for conspiracy
to support The Killing of Americans
through a Colombian terrorist
organization now initially negotiations
said Paul Whelan a canadian-born
American Marine would be part of that
deal but in December it seems like that
fell apart and that wouldn't happen
that's going to be a huge criticism on
one part great we have an American
citizen back home but many people are
asking why do we exchange a WNBA player
for about uh for a arms dealer and what
about the Marine that was left behind
for almost four years now come December
28th yeah it's a difficult situation and
I think we'll all be following to see if
there's any developments with Paul
Whalen now moving over to Courtney
klenny that hearing that also happened
on Thursday well the judge in her murder
trial was considering whether to allow
clenny out on bond after hearing
arguments from the prosecution in
defense at an Arthur hearing last month
and on Thursday the judge denied the
request for bail during the Arthur
hearing which is basically a mini trial
the prosecution and the defense agreed
that the one-time only fans model and
her boyfriend Cristiano mselli had a
volatile abuse relationship during an
argument in April clenny allegedly threw
a knife at obam Sully hitting an artery
and he bled out in their Miami condo but
clenny's legal team says she was only
protecting herself
in her ruling judge Laura Cruz wrote
that when the crime a person is charged
with is punishable with life in prison
and their guilt is evident they can't be
released before trial the order also
states that the court does not find the
defendant's claims of self-defense
credible despite requests from clenny's
lawyers for her to change her mind the
judge didn't waver
your honor stated that you didn't feel
comfortable having her released on house
arrest to her parents in Texas there is
an inpatient treatment program in Boca
if she's monitored by the Miami-Dade
Community Corrections Department on home
confinement and would I think hopefully
alleviate some of the Court's concerns
the judge I don't believe it requires
response there are no conditions that
will ensure her presence and the safety
of the community and we disagree with
any release to any inpatient people
all right now I want to bring in co-host
a former trial Attorney Terry Austin to
talk about this so Terry Courtney clenny
might be well known on social media but
the judge basically treated her just
like any other defendant right you know
what Jesse that's exactly right Courtney
clenny may have millions of online fans
but judge Laura Cruz is definitely not
one of them during the art the hearing
judge Cruz listened to cliny's defense
team reiterate why she should be
released on bond pending trial in
Florida capital offenses like murder are
classified as what they call no bond
offenses if a defendant is charged with
one of those crimes they will only be
released before trial if they can
demonstrate that they are not a danger
to society and that they are not a
Flight Risk clinty sat quietly on the
side of the courtroom near another
female prisoner who seemed familiar with
the system in contrast Clinic seemed
visibly distraught and was ultimately
consoled by her attorneys her defense
team told the judge that cliny could
remain in her parents home with a
monitoring device or even moved to a
special facility where she could be
monitored more closely but the judge was
not buying it and she said look you are
staying in prison you're a fight risk
you're not getting out yep that's very
two different situations right there
moving over to disgraced Hollywood Mogul
Harvey Weinstein while he awaits his
fate in Los Angeles as deliberations
continue in his sex assault trial eight
women testified against Weinstein in
this trial where he faces seven sexual
assault charges and a possible life
sentence Weinstein did not take the
stand in his own defense but his team
argued that the accusers were either
untruthful or that they had consensual
sexual relationships with him this is
Weinstein's second sexual assault trial
after being convicted on similar charges
two years ago in New York he's serving a
23-year prison sentence in that case and
an appeal was recently granted now in
Los Angeles the jury panel has been at
it for four plus days with no questions
posed on